this morning anti-coup protests in
myanmar took a significant turn when
police killed at least two protesters in
the city of mandalay
this happened after two full weeks of
demonstrations in the country formerly
known
as burma also this morning anti-coup
protesters in two of that nation's
largest cities
paused to remember a young woman who
died on friday
she was shot by police during a rally
against the military takeover
it follows the arrest of longtime
democratic leader aung san soo chi and
is further proof
the country's decade-long experiment
with democracy has come to an end
raymie and ascencio reports from beijing
and a warning
some of the video you're about to see
may be disturbing to some viewers
in myanmar's flaring anti-coup protests
the first life was taken with a pop
twenty-year-old mia twente king crumpled
to the ground
shot in the head by police february 9.
her body carried from this hospital
friday doctors declared her brain dead
and removed her ventilator mia's sister
unflinching called on every citizen to
protest
under the cover of darkness february 1st
the junta staged its coup
arresting aung san tsuchi myanmar's top
civilian leader
and more than 400 allies alleging
massive election fraud in november's
parliamentary elections
it is outrageous and it is simply
unacceptable
tom andrews is the un's special
repertoire on myanmar
the biggest fear of the people in
myanmar
is going back uh to live under a
authoritarian military regime
hence this cdm this civil disobedience
movement
now breaking out these painted road
signs emulated those from blm
the us's black lives matter movement
in yangon myanmar's most populous city
demonstrators spilled fruits on the road
and cars broke down on mass to slow
the military's movements buddhist monks
marched to denounce the coup
and the lgbt community even held a pride
parade in solidarity
with the three-fingered hunger games
salute
the junta has charged aung san tsuchi
with illegally possessing
six walkie-talkies and breaking a
natural disaster law
on tuesday military leaders claimed
their power grab was to
protect democracy i don't know what
planet they're on
but if you don't want to interrupt
progress to democracy
you don't have a coup how do you think
this might end
my fear is that that a lot of people
lose their lives
at the hands of this military as they
have in the past
as memorials rise to mia twente keen she
is this protest's
first martyr and anti-coup protesters
have said they will
not stop until aung san tsuchi is free
but
the military juntu can really detain her
for as long as they like
one protest leader though did say we
must be
the last generation to experience a coup
for cbs this morning saturday
ramy in ascencio beijing